quand on est citadin compass il ya un
côté majestueux dans les éoliennes qui
tourne ne l'entend pas et quand on vit à
côté c'est invivable
ainsi parlait jean germain le pourtant
très citadin sénateurs d'indre et loire
mais dans les campagnes les habitants
des villages souffre-t-il réellement ce
point de la proximité des éoliennes
voici a contrario l'exemple de saint
georges sur arnon 19 éoliennes 600
habitants dont véronique brel la plus
proche du parc éolien est donc au bout
de votre jardin on voit effectivement le
parc éolien oui effectivement
et alors que comment vous le vivez ça
très bien qu'est ce que je vous dise
d'autre
il faut croire que cet avis est partagé
à saint georges sur arnon puisque le
maire jacques pallas est réélu sans
discontinuer depuis près de 20 ans or
c'est lui qui a été à l'initiative de ce
parc éolien le premier construit dans
l'indre en voici de retombées
économiques
d'abord pour les propriétaires des
terres pour les agriculteurs donc c'est
un chiffre qui est national qui est
applicable à l'ensemble des
propriétaires de pied des éoliennes il
aura peu près 5000 à 600 euros par an et
pour les collectivités locales le
chiffre exact ces 10000 euros par
mégawatt
c'est à dire le département
l'intercommunalité et les communes donc
4000 euros pour la commune de saint
georges
ça me fait 140 mille euros de recettes
fiscales tous les ans une manne qui a
permis de baisser la taxe foncière sont
réduire les ambitions d'un plan communal
globale environnementale avec des audits
énergétiques pour les particuliers avec
la construction d'une médiathèque isolés
par des écomatériaux avec un mur
végétalisé notamment est équipé d'un
récupérateur d'eau de pluie
l'os est l'autre priorité en effet trois
réseaux d'assainissement ont été
construits afin de rejeter une eau
propre dans l'art long la rivière elle
même a été réhabilité en recréant des
frayères à poissons et en permettant à
ces poissons et aux sédiments de ne plus
être bloqué par des barrages
la commune veut aller plus loin nous
avons un projet de 11 éoliennes
supplémentaires au milieu des deux
lignes qu'il ya derrière moi vous les
voyez les deux lignes c'est au milieu
voilà tout simplement en fait c'est une
densification à l'intérieur du pag
résistants mais cette fois c'est
l'ensemble des revenus générés par les
éoliennes qui reviendra aux habitants on
aura toujours un porteur de projet tout
le temps mais par contre au niveau de
l'exploitation du fonctionnement et de
la gestion donc des dividendes des
recettes
ça sera donc pour les citoyens du pays
cela leur apportera quoi et c'est bloqué
combien de temps on bloque les cinq
premières années
ensuite le rapport sur tournerait autour
de 5% sauf que ce projet ne pourrait pas
voir le jour si la loi proposé par le
sénateur germain était définitivement
adopté en doublant la distance
obligatoire entre les parcs éoliens les
habitations a très clairement le schéma
régional éolien serait absolument
complètement à revoir puisque la
puissance kaki installée ne serait plus
possible aurait effectivement une
pratiquement pas de possibilité
d'installation new and here lien sur la
région centre et ce qui est vrai pour la
région le serait pour l'ensemble du
territoire français en attendant les
oiseaux migrateurs survol tranquillement
le parc éolien berrichon après être
passée au-dessus de la ville voisine
issoudun dans les quatorze mille
habitants sont alimentés en électricité
pour l'éclairage chauffage et leurs
activités industrielles dans les dix
neuf éoliennes de saint georges sur
arnon